bonsoir à ceux qui nous rejoignent en
cours nous venons de voir ce
documentaire de 52 minutes signée lionel
boisseau et thierry jeantet consacré aux
cyclones irma josé maria et leurs
conséquences catastrophiques comme nous
avons pu le voir pour aller plus loin
sur la question du niveau de préparation
de la martinique face aux ouragans
majeurs
nous recevons ce soir trois invités jean
noël de grâce bonsoir alors vous êtes
monsieur météo pour nous en martinique
on ne vous présente plus vous êtes
particulièrement sollicités à chaque
période cyclonique et chacune de vos
interventions et décortiqué parfois même
critiqué par une partie de la population
nous verrons en quoi vos prévisions
reste cruciale pour la martinique et
nous essaierons de répondre à cette
question sommes nous prêts à faire face
à un ouragan majeur
franck robine bonsoir vous êtes préfet
de martinique dont soeur votre rôle ne
se limite pas à notre seul il puisque
vous êtes responsable de la zone de
défense anti en ce qui concerne les
risques majeurs c'est vous qui décidez
des différents niveaux d' alerte en
fonction des informations fournies par
météo france
et là aussi vous avez pu être critiqué
récemment nous allons en parler tout à
l'heure nous essaierons de comprendre
avec vous les différents processus qui
se met en place en cas de cyclones et
l'autre troisième invité ses albéric
marcellin bonsoir bonsoir président de
l'université populaire de la prévention
vous êtes très impliqué en ce qui
concerne la prévention des risques
majeurs en martinique en cette période
cyclonique vous tirer comme toujours la
sonnette d'alarmé en disant que selon
vous nous ne sommes absolument pas prêts
à faire face à un ouragan majeur puisque
ce soir il sera question d'ouragan tant
au niveau de la population que de nos
institutions où il ya encore du travail
selon alors première question à monsieur
robin le préfet pour revenir au
documentaire que nous venons de voir on
se rappelle qu'à l'époque il y avait eu
de vives critiques sur la rapidité
d'intervention des secours et des
services de l'état et sur la hauteur des
moyens qui avait été engagé et cela pas
seulement d'ailleurs au niveau local
puisque des responsables politiques au
niveau national réclamé même à l'époque
une enquête parlementaire à ce sujet
avec du recul
aujourd'hui un an plus tard est ce que
vous considérez que la réponse de l'état
avait été à la hauteur finale
sur les actions des services de secours
c'est-à-dire des sapeurs pompiers de la
sécurité civile
indéniablement l'état était présent et
je ne crois pas que les critiques et
porté sur cet aspect là j'en veux pour
preuve d'ailleurs que nous avions
prépositionné des unités de la sécurité
civile qui avait été envoyée depuis
paris qui avaient été prépositionnés
directement sur l'île de saint-martin
c'était la même chose d'ailleurs pour
des unités militaires au total en avait
à peu près une centaine d'hommes qui
avaient été prépositionnés donc je pense
que d'ailleurs s'il n'y a pas eu de
commission d' enquête parlementaire
c'est parce que la réalité un peu ramené
des uns et des autres à la raison
très bien elle rejoindra le brass on a
vu aussi dans le documentaire la
difficulté qu'il y avait à obtenir des
prévisions plutôt précise et ceux ci le
plus tôt possible afin de sécuriser les
populations d'anticiper aussi les
secours a déployé à la danse avant le
cyclone oui alors c'est vrai que on a
tous envie d'être extrêmement précis une
semaine avant ce pourquoi pas 15 jours
l'as vence
le problème c'est d'intégrer les
incertitudes et donc les probabilités de
passage mais surtout quand il s'agit
d'un ouragan majeur
et quand il s'est dit jeanne ouragan
majeur sincèrement la trajectoire à 50
cents kilomètres près n'est pas un
problème
l'intensité catégorie 3 catégories
quatre catégories 5 n'est pas un
problème non plus pas un problème en
tant d'impact mais en termes de
prévisions de montée en puissance des
systèmes de vigilance des systèmes
d'alerté préfecture on est sur un chemin
qui est relativement bien tracée parce
que même une probabilité de 5%
de passage à nogaro majeure ne peut pas
être négligée par l'ensemble des acteurs
de la sécurité d'accor
alors quand tu avoues albéric marcellin
avec votre regard vous qui travaillaient
autour de la prévention
comment est ce que vous aviez vécu ces
épisodes cycloniques i am ya tout juste
1 écoutez d'abord j'ai bien suivi cette
affaire là parce que votre association
est très impliqué mais on s'est surtout
souvenu de ce qui s'est passé le 17 août
2007 avec dean bon et je crois que quand
même qu'il faut rappeler aux uns et aux
autres que c'était
de catégorie 2 qui a quand même laissé
des traces ici un donc quatre mots dans
un suicide
si 7650 de maisons qui ont été détruites
dans 1318 ont été détruites à 100% 511
millions d'euros de dommages donc
c'était quand même assez de l'eau et
puis pour la petite anecdote le préfet
de l'époque qui avait et a subi quelques
dommages cela les aspects fektera et qui
dormait un capes bon ça c'était pour la
petite anecdote
donc c'était de la catégorie 2 ce sont
bien la première fois qu'on est à vue
une catégorie 5 dans la zone est là
aujourd'hui nous sommes inquiets parce
que nous sommes dans une zone éminemment
exposés aux world un majeur et on a le
sentiment que la population
martiniquaise n'a pas encore bien cibler
ce que c'est que nous un gain majeur
malgré dean en 2007 on dit aujourd'hui
par exemple si on venait à vivre un
ouragan que la fin qu est-ce que selon
vous la population est prête par exemple
ou psychologiquement à recevoir cette
information et puis à la traiter à se
comporter en fonction mais souvent on
parle de mémoire collectif enfin avoir
les bonnes réactions
à votre avis combien d'ouragans majeurs
ont frappé la martinique depuis 1950
ok donc zéro des ouragans qui ont
atterri sur les côtes de martinique
comme il y en a eu depuis 1956 parle pas
de raison majeure à zéro parce que jean
est passé dans le canal de sainte-lucie
l'était pas c'était pas de plein fouet
martinique ça veut dire que on ne peut
pas se baser sur ce qu'on a vécu pour
savoir ce qui peut se passer alors bien
sûr on peut regarder les documentaires
on peut regarder des images mais nous
notre rôle c'est justement aussi
d'informer alors d'informer sur la
prévision certes en temps réel c'est
important mais il faut qu'on travaille
tous ensemble que ce soit tous les
services de l'état que ce soit avec les
associations les collectivités sur la
préparation par rapport à des
informations météo mais la préparation
s'est pas non plus que avançons
cyclonique c'est à dire la préparation
sur l'aménagement du territoire sur des
procédures surinformation population et
celle là que effectivement on voit qu'on
peut entre guillemets gagner parce qu'on
voit que fait un reportage où il ya 90
95 % des habitations endommagées
il faut se poser la question c'est ça du
coup je me tourne vers vous franck
robine est ce qu'on est prêt et comment
est-ce qu'on se prépare concrètement à
faire face à un ouragan majeur qui
pourrait être de la force d'irma voire
plus
on sait que des des pics de vent à 370
km heure avait été enregistré parfois
donc pour nous il y en a comment est-ce
qu'on se prépare concrètement quand on
en a jamais affronté alors moi je veux
j'ai vraiment en tête dans cet épisode
les paroles de roosevelt skerrit le
premier ministre de la dominique
qui a dit nous avons perdu tout ce qui
peut être perdu et derrière c'est vous
qui sont qui sont poignants il ya toute
la question de comment est ce qu'on est
capable collectivement je reprends les
mots de jean noël de grâce non seulement
l'état avec les services mine bien
évidemment il ya eu en y remet à un
avant irma josémaria il ya un après et
un après ça veut dire qu'on maintenant
on sait que oui d un ouragan majeur peut
toucher les antilles avec des vents qui
ont atteint 370 quasiment 400 km h en
rafales et donc on a pris un certain
nombre d'enseignements jeudi un certain
nombre sans doute qu'il y en a encore
attiré en terme de préparation des
services en termes de sensibilisation de
la population est ce que fait monsieur
marcellin est extrêmement important pour
vraiment être capable de toucher chaque
martiniquais chaque martiniquaise
directement et puis il y a aussi un
certain nombre d'enseignements tu pu
être tiré en terme d'aménagement de
construction
je vais je vais vous donner un exemple
c'est ce qu'on ait des éléments après
saint-martin enfin après irma le cstb
clic et le centre technique du ministère
de l'equipement a tout simplement fait
une brochure qui qui s'appelle un guide
pratique dite des bonnes pratiques qui
est disponible d'ailleurs sur le sur le
site internet pour la construction et la
réhabilitation de l'habitat et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que bien sûr il ya
des normes bien sûr il ya l'état qui
doit faire appliquer les normes qui doit
les contrôler mais il ya aussi un
certain nombre de choses très concrètes
que les anciens respecté a ramassé
d'ailleurs moi je pose la question est
ce que il est raisonnable dès lors que
l'on sait qu'il ya des possibilités de
d'ouragans majeurs de construire des
maisons entières en baie vitrée la
question la question est posée voilà je
sais présente pratique il ya bien sûr
beaucoup d'autres enseignements qui
peuvent être vous pouvez de la
construction et ça m'amène justement à
une interview que nous avons fait
aujourd'hui avec christian chams qui est
directeur général de chd technique
contrôle c'est un bureau de contrôle
technique agréé dans la construction
alors ça parle de la construction
déconstruction d'aujourd'hui qui peuvent
résister pour l'instant en tout cas à
des vents de 231 km heure 250 km heure
en moyenne c'est ce que la norme prévoit
il s'agit au départ de calcul de
pression qui se traduise ensuite par an
devant une vitesse précise qu'en
serait-il alors du coup on lui a demandé
si nos habitations affrontait des ventes
plus de 350 kilomètres heure mais
éléments de réponse
regardez il ya ce qu'on appelle des
effets de ce qui fait donc lié à la
l'emplacement de la construction par
rapport à 10 fois des montagnes des
grands bâtiments
il ya des effets d'accélération du vent
des effets de réduction donc c'est un
petit peu complexe à ce niveau donc on
peut pas donner une réponse précise bon
bien entendu avec des vents très forts
il est évident que ça va pas résister 1
bon maintenant on sait calculer pour des
recettes puissance c'est une question de
choix et de réglementation est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il faudrait qu'on change la
réglementation en sachant qu'avec le
réchauffement climatique on va avoir des
ouragans majeurs la plupart du temps
pour l'instant la réflexion est menée
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de décision
encore parce qu'on est sur la base d'un
seul phénomène mais il est évident que
si ce type de phénomène ne venait à a
évolué en termes de densité d'intensité
de fréquences dans le temps il est
évident que l'implémentation allait
évoluer en terme de niveau de défiance
appartement maison c'est différent les
appartements sont dans des immeubles en
béton en mai s'ouvre donc il ya quand
même cette insécurité globale souvent
cité pour les problématiques surtout sur
les menuiseries extérieures qui peuvent
exploser avec des formes d'efforts vente
pour les maisons individuelles
on est mitigé puisque en fait il faut
savoir que il ya à peine 20 % qui sont
faites par les architectes et dessus 500
contre les bons débuts de contrôle donc
partant de ce principe on a quand même
eu beaucoup de maisons qui sont faites
dans des conditions à bien sûr et les
constructions des besoins des
constructeurs de maisons individuelles
qui sont effectivement compétent et
qu'il doit respecter réglementation mais
pour ceux qui sont à livrer on ne peut
pas garantir effectivement la stabilité
de ce genre de structure sont nombreux
alors franck robin est ce qu'on
réfléchisse changement cette évolution
des normes de construction absolument
d'ailleurs le président de la république
vient de le rappeler à saint martin
dimanche dernier le cstb a été saisie
donc l'organisme quel jeu lyon a été
saisie
c'est lui qui a fait l'enquète sur ce
qui s'est passé à saint martin à saint
martin
vous l'avez dit à peu près 90 95 % des
maisons ont été touchées
fort heureusement seulement 20% ont été
complètement détruites qui est en soit
important après tout dépend de la
configuration du terrain votre votre
expert l'a bien dit donc le cstb va
étudier des nouvelles normes
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
qu'on est aussi obligé de faire
aujourd'hui avec l'existant d'où la mise
en place de ce guide des bonnes
pratiques et moi même j'ai lancé deux
actions très concrètes depuis irma
josémaria d'une part un plan de contrôle
des bétons ce qui vaut d'ailleurs pour
le risque cyclonique où le risque
sismique est puis une étude convient de
lancer qui sera réalisée partie cette
année au cours de l'année prochaine sur
la solidité des bâtiments publics
donc il ya cinquante mille euros qui ont
été dégagés à cet effet et notamment les
bâtiments qui peuvent servir de refuge
que les mairies mettre en place de
manière à s'assurer de la séquelle de
leurs solidités vis-à-vis des vents
cycloniques et vis-à-vis du risque
sismique très bien alors et l'autre
l'autre est question importante c'est
toujours en matière de prévisions
météorologiques alors on a aussi cette
polémique en martinique tout le temps on
se dit voilà les américains arrivent à
mieux prévoir ce genre de d'ouragan ce
genre d'évènements que nous en
martinique
qu'en est il véritablement on parle tout
le temps du nhc
est-ce qu'on travaille avec eux comment
est-ce que ça se passe concrètement dire
c'est pas un sujet il n'y a pas de
compétition le mode mythologiques et le
monde le plus ouvert on partage le plus
l'organisation mondiale a décidé
d'optimiser les moyens des services
météo a dit ok il ya un centre régional
qui a besoin de beaucoup de moyens qui
va travailler avec les données des
autres pays dont la france dont l'europe
pour faire une prévision qui est
consensuelle
imaginez vous que on a une prévision en
dominique à sainte lucie en martinique
qui soit différente avec des timing
différent avec des intensités
différentes c'est hyper dur à gérer donc
la meilleure prévision possible est fait
de façon régional pour la petite
histoire
le nhc américain s'appuie énormément sur
le modèle européen
c'est pas donc voyez que c'est pas de la
guerre c'est vraiment c'est vraiment de
la mutualisation de la coopération et de
la coopération coopération y compris en
temps réel vidéo le reportage le
responsable de la prévision il est au
téléphone il appelle les prévisionnistes
du nhc ça fonctionne comme ça c'est pas
du montage c'est pas de l'acteur studio
c'est la réalité et on rappelle
notamment que le nhc fait des vols
réguliers pour rentrer alors ça on le
sait est important c'est le seul bassin
du monde où on a la chance il faut le
dire clairement d'avoir des missions
d'avion qui viennent mesurer ce qui se
passe d'un ouragan parce que pour bien
prévoir à nora grand mais il faut déjà
bien l'observer bien le mesurer et bien
analyser les informations qui nous sont
des informations qui sont transmises
après la formation supplémentaire que
sous la porte et c'est il faut
maintenant aussi qu'on sache nous
services météo le service scientifique
avoir une approche qui soit vraiment
plus orienté dès de la décision pourquoi
il faut qu'on arrête de dire il y aura
des vents de 150 km heure il y aura 100
mm de pluie ou lure à cinq mètres de
vagues ce dont ont besoin les gens c'est
qu'elle voit que les conséquences ce
qu'elle voit que les a pas donc il faut
qu'on se et ça c'est un cadre mondial de
faire de la prévision d'impact
il faut qu'on sache répondre à un préfet
qui nous dit qu'elle population g doit
évacuer en priorité par exemple que vous
puissiez dire fait et ça vous c'est pas
un travail uniquement de météo france
et là encore il faut que l'ensemble des
acteurs scientifiques au service des
acteurs la sécurité se mette ensemble
c'est ce qu'on commence à faire en
martinique on a des météorologues météo
france qui travaille avec des
hydrologues delà des halles
parce que les pluies qui tombent on sait
bien que ce n'est pas la pluie qui est
dangereuse c'est ce qu'elle entraîne
c'est sur les crues éclairs les coulées
de boue ainsi de suite donc il faut
mettre les compétences multiples on sait
qu'après pour savoir s'il qu'alain
vulnérables et bien c'est des
compétences peut-être du brgm peut-être
delà des halles qui sont voilà donc il
faut qu'on travaille ensemble sur la
préparation et à dire le avant le
pendant est le après oui parce que alors
rappelons le quand même nous parlons
aujourd'hui de cyclones mais vous me
précisiez l'ordre quand on préparait
cette émission que le risque le plus
important pour vous c'est pas tant le
vent finalement
c'est plutôt l'eau alors le vent on se
focalise dessus parce que c'est ce qui
sert à caractériser des cyclones alors
le vent il est dangereux parce qu'ils
transportent
donc c'est vrai que et ça quand on
discute avec des ingénieurs structurel
de bâtiments ils savent bien dit oui ok
des baies vitrées et ça résiste à 250
kilomètres heure sauf si ça prend un
gros projectiles donc la roue voilà le
danger du vent il est là par contre ce
qui fait le plus de victimes au mans de
plus de dégâts c'est la mère d'abord et
l'eau des rivières crues éclairs coulées
de boue ensuite et ça c'est vrai et que
ça soit la submersion marine cerveau qui
est souvent un petit peu compliqué mais
ça veut dire ça ça veut dire de l'eau
qui a envahi des terres des vagues qui
se rajoutent par dessus ça ça détruit
beaucoup plus que le monde d'accord
alors en tout cas on a bien compris que
la priorité aujourd'hui de tous les
chercheurs spécialisés la météo ces deux
d'être de plus en plus précis sur la
prévision de ces phénomènes aujourd'hui
les chercheurs donc essaie par tous les
moyens de savoir notamment ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur des ouragans
le nhc on l'a dit tout à l'heure utilise
des avions pour ça dans le cas de maria
il y a une trentaine de vols pour mieux
étudier le phénomène mais à toulouse
comme on l'a vu également dans le
documentaire le projet aéro clippers
vise à envoyer des ballons aux quarts
des ouragans
après une longue quête de financement
les travaux ont redémarré en 2015 les
prochains essais sont prévus dans un an
dans l'océan indien puis dans le
pacifique enfin dans la caraïbe nous
avons recueillis au téléphone les
précisions de jean philippe duval qui
est directeur de recherche au cnrs on
l'écoutait pense faire les premiers
temps réel dans le pacifique nord web en
coopération avec les agences
météorologique japonaise
et ensuite en 2021 dans le sang indien
en coopération avec météo france et le
centre de prévisons de cyclos de la
réunion et en peut-être en coopération
justement avec la noaa américaine
également qui amènerait un avion sur
place donc on pourrait avoir des mesures
conjointes d'aero clippers et des
mesures faites depuis l'avion de la
norme
je ferai très intéressant avant la
complémentarité des certaine
complémentarité qui pourrait ensuite
réutilisés sur l'atlantique nord donc
les régions caraïbes
sachant que l'hérault clippers va
apporter donc cette mesure en continu en
surface
donc de la pression de surfer au centre
du cyclone qui permettent de détecter
des implications rapide des systèmes ou
au contraire des dissipation du système
et qui permet aussi idéalement deux
guides et éventuellement les avions de
participer en fait aux plans de vol des
avions pour que l'avion puisse
intervenir peut-être dans des phases qui
sont plus intéressantes et que d'autres
en particulier sur la prévision du
système vers l'assimilation de cet
ensemble donné dans les modèles de
prévision pour avoir des prévisions par
la suite plus plus précise alors on va
parler tout à l'heure des différents
niveaux de vigilance mais juste avant l
bêtement cela j'aimerais qu'on voit avec
vous vous êtes donc au contact de la
population est très régulièrement
comment est ce que vous les sentez
concrètement et comment est ce que vous
arrivez à quand même faire passer le
message qu'il faut se préparer
matériellement et psychologiquement
également alors trois jours après le
cyclone hugo en 1989 j'étais sur le
terrain apprête à pitre avec moi comme
un veau si bien et on a entendu les
guadeloupéens nous adressent un message
en créole qui est le suivant sa kippa
connaître cyclone passe jamais demandé
qu'on est recyclé ça a fait son chemin
tant est que les gens ont oublié
bon alors c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement dangereux parce qu'on a vu
sur porto rico sur saint martin saint
barthélémy et ailleurs il ya des gens
qui ont perdu leur entreprise donc
chômage qui ont perdu leur habitation
un choc psychologique etc etc alors au
niveau de l'université pour la
prévention on continue de dire les
consignes d'organiser avec les citoyens
une meilleure manière de prise en compte
de cet aspect du problème mais on est
allé beaucoup plus loin que ça
aujourd'hui on en est à proposer aux
services de l'état et au gouvernement
par exemple la mise en place d'un plan
global général le fameux plan poma ça
des implants ohada majeur antilles et
pour nous c'est simplement au regard
d'un petit peu ce qui s'est passé après
le tremblement de terre du 21 novembre
2004 au 7 qui avait une petite fille de
7 ans et là le gouvernement avait décidé
de mettre en place le plan séisme
antilles sur 15 ans
chiffre est à peu près 5 milliards
d'euros pour la martinique et pour la
guadeloupe sur l'aspect ouragans nous
avons relevé la par exemple avec 35,8 m
il y a énormément de choses à faire donc
nous voulons vivement que ce plan là
soient mises en place parce que nos
arguant de catégorie 5 que le laissera
la martinique à genoux et les meilleurs
experts au niveau international de côté
le cd v par exemple nous disent que nous
sommes un majeur sur une île c'est 15
ans de retard sur l'horloge de
développement économique du pays
quand on sait aujourd'hui que nous
sommes menacés et j'invite tous les
martiniquais à prendre ce risque là deux
doigts d'un majeur en ligne de compte et
surtout de cesser ce qu'on a entendu
autour d'isaac autour d'isaac c'est un
oui l'ailé
dans les médias les médias sociaux et
cetera attention si on avait un paysage
en catégorie cinq la martinique serait à
genoux donc de grâce mais je demande à
nos compatriotes martiniquais de
d'intégrer ce risque-là et d'intégrer
aussi d'autres risques extrêmement
important m'ont fait qu'on soit là on a
vécu un truc assez extraordinaire pour
dean la veille on a eu un séisme et on a
utilisé le 17 août
là cette fois ci on avait la menace de
quille et le lendemain à 8h 30 noeuds on
a eu un séisme de magnitude 6,3 a dit
que m de profondeur et ce sur quoi les
gens doivent c'était un peu le même
c'est que nous serions à un degré
supplémentaire ça ferait 7,3 de
magnitude à 10 km de profondeur
nous serions comme haïti le 12 janvier
2010 il faut que les gens comprennent ça
donc pour nous il faut travailler sur
l'ensemble des problématiques et je
terminerai quand même là dessus sur
l'aspect des normes bon j'ai entendu un
certain nombre de choses
je crois que aujourd'hui il faut
fusionner l'eurocode 8 qui est la norme
européenne sur les risques sismiques et
le au code 1 1,4 sur le risque
cyclonique
et puis augmentez justement la meilleure
protection de nos populations
il faudra aussi mettre des budgets
pousse alors ce débat malheureusement
est très court il nous reste à peine
quelques minutes mais ce que j'aimerais
déjà qu'on puisse mettre au clair c'est
ce débat qui a lieu tout le temps vous
parliez albéric marcellin on remet tout
en cause les niveaux de visite
ce qu'ils sont décidés est ce qu'on doit
faire les enfants restés chez eux ne pas
aller à l'école
comment est ce qu'on prend ses décisions
elles sont basées sur quoi je vous
regarde tous les deux parce que je sais
que ce sont des décisions qui sont
prises ensemble lequel d'entre vous a
envie de répondre là dessus je vais
commencer parce qu'effectivement la
vigilance et finalement la façon
d'évaluer le danger est en fonction de
cette évaluation du danger les autorités
préfectorales prennent des mesures
collectives qui constitue la l'erc
alors on l'a dit on a un système qui
doit être capable de gérer des
incertitudes des probabilités faibles
mais avec des impacts potentiellement
majeur et ça ça demande une montée en
puissance progressive
forcément quand on anticipe de trois
jours la prévision est qu'on est en
vigilance jaune cyclone ça veut dire
qu'on sait qu' il y aura un
rassemblement 200 250 km d'erreurs qui
aura des problèmes de d'intensité de
pluie de choses comme ça mais on ne peut
pas faire autrement que d'anticiper
parce que c'est la demande sociétale
c'est la demande des acteurs de la
sécurité cela demande monsieur le préfet
parlait de positionnement du pré
positionnement des secours lors d'irma
mais c'est quelque chose qui va
s'anticiper trois jours à l'avance
d'accord donc on a obligé on obligé
d'être au delà de ce qu'on sait faire
précisément donc la vigilance elle sert
à ça elle sera montée en puissance
pourquoi parce qu on sait aussi que
chaque citoyen qui est normalement les
premiers acteurs de sa sécurité a besoin
de temps pour se préparer parce que
malheureusement tout n'est pas fait
comme on le souhaiterait aussi bien
avant mais je on a besoin que ce soit
pour deux habitations pour nos
entreprises pour donc cette monte en
puissance elle est normale et elle est
forcément régulière et elle est
forcément entachées d'incertitude et on
va venir et je le dis parce que c'est
mon souhait on va venir à de
l'information qui bat de plus en plus
probabiliste il faut s'habituer à ça
parce que c'est c'est le nerf de la
gestion du risque
on va sortir et que centenaire de dire
vous prouvera que jamais d'avoir je
reprends mon coeur que c'est encore plus
récent coeur le risque d'avoir des vents
cycloniques sur la martinique est de
l'ordre de
10 % il ya 90 % qu'on est plutôt de la
pluie
voilà et donc nous on niveau de
l'ensemble des acteurs qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ce 10% mais c'est le préfet
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous avez à
ajouter à ce tout ce processus de
décision et puis est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire où en est la
proposition faite par monsieur marcellin
marceline au sujet de ce plan
d'abord sur la dernière question le
président de la république annoncé à
saint martin dimanche encore qu'un plan
d'action spécifique sur les risques
naturels seraient à préparer avant l'été
donc c'est l'ensemble des projets des
projets donc ça répond tout à fait à
cette interrogation sur les niveaux
d'alarmé ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que la population doit s'impliquer
dans la gestion des risques le niveau
jeunes ça veut dire aux martiniquais ou
martiniquaise attention il peut se
passer quelque chose
est ce que j'ai fait des provisions
est-ce que je m'ennuie à mon habitation
est prête
le niveau orange ça veut dire il se peut
qu'il y ait des plus importantes des
vents importants
est ce que je suis prêt à entrer pour
les écoles
oui je l'assument nous préférons fermer
les écoles lorsque nous sommes en orange
tout simplement pour ne pas que les
enfants se retrouvent sur les routes au
moment où il est probable que l'appui
sera la plus forte
lorsque nous sommes en rouge et au
dollar comme pour maria l'aînée dernière
en violet là évidemment c'est une
protection absolue et il faut bien
comprendre que ces niveaux d' alerte
ils sont là pour impliquer la
polarisation la dernière petite chose
que je peux dire le mot de la fin
il faut aussi avoir conscience que nous
sommes dans une petite région sur des
îles qui finalement ne sont pas très
grande et kirk l'a bien montré
kirk a changé de trajectoire au dernier
moment et c'est malheureusement sainte
lucie qui après tout plots qu'on avait
prévu mes seins plus de 40 km
de la martinique donc c'est vraiment un
côté et donc moi je voudrais vraiment
souligner c'est que nous sommes tous
impliqués dans la gestion et qu'une
toute petite modification trajectoire
peut nous concerner nous n'allons pas
nous concerner absolument en tout cas je
vous remercie à tous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et d'avoir participé à
ce débat
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis c'est
la fin de cette émission rendez vous le
mois prochain pour un nouveau numéro de
résonance
[Musique]